[Music]
Cordo dashboards is a new feature that
is coming to Cordo in the 1.4 release uh
and uh it's something that we we really
um decided to add on the heels uh of the
most recent posit conference and so it
wasn't originally on the plan for 1.4
but we decided to take a little bit of
extra time and see if we could squeeze
it in um obviously um the goal of Cordo
dashboards um is uh pretty simple make
it easy to build compelling Interactive
dashboards uh using our python Julia
observable um and very much um sort of a
Heritage of flex dashboard um you know
so very much sort of bring Flex
dashboard and that type of experience
into Cordo uh incorporate everything
we've learned uh everything the company
has built and try to bring that together
into a really great experience for our
users um dashboards um in Cordo are are
pretty straightforward uh they're
basically composed of cards so you can
think about cards as just sort of the
units the atomic units that you're
arranging in a dashboard and you arrange
those cards into rows and columns to lay
them out and then you can use things
like P Pages tab sets and sidebars to
sort of incorporate more advanced layout
to incorporate controls and other things
that might might need to appear in the
dashboard um but with those simple
building blocks it's actually pretty
easy to build some cool
dashboards um so let's let's build a
simple dashboard let's see if we can do
this so let's just start from scratch
I've got a qmd that I've got going here
and I'm just going to start with the
front matter my
dashboard and let's make it format
dashboard uh and then let's just put in
for now we're going to we're going to
explore my lack of R programming skills
but let's just put in uh a simple static
plot to
start and then let's uh have a look at
what we get uh and so oops we're not
quite fitting on the screen hang
on uh there we
go uh and so you can see now I've gotten
okay I guess I've gotten you know a
little title bar I've gotten one big
card uh and so you can see you know the
treatment is already a little different
than just a simple web page um because
we're sort of filling the whole screen
and in fact as we add elements to this
dashboard like let's add a second plot
to this dashboard
it sort of knows enough to lay things
out appropriately so it just made two
two different cards here uh and the
cards contain the
visualization but of course I may want
to start to do some cooler things to
sort of tune this up a little bit so uh
let's start by putting a title on some
of these cards uh so let's go title you
know cars plot and then we'll add a
title down
here Mt
cars
plot
uh you know and we're starting to
starting to see okay now we're getting
it's getting better um I wonder if those
might look better side by side well in
Cordo dashboards you use headings to
arrange things uh and so uh by adding a
simple heading I can basically say okay
I'd like to you know I guess maybe maybe
the way to explain it is to do this is
to say you know dashboards have sort of
an
orientation uh which by default is rows
so by default it's saying just
everything that shows up is a row I
could change that and say actually like
let's make everything columns instead
and so when I do that we'll actually get
the layout now into
columns uh similarly uh if I said let's
go back to rows just the good old basic
orientation that we had if I said I want
to make a row explicitly I can add a
heading and say Here's a row that I made
and so I made a row and the row has two
things side by side in it it'll get even
easier to see if I do something like
make another row and put some content in
it
here's some
content so now I have made a
dashboard that basically uh has here a
row with some content in it and then
here a row with the plots in it and you
can see that looks very straightforward
uh and so that gives you the basic idea
of arranging things now you know you can
keep going so you know I could say uh
I'm going to make a column inside here H
and then I'm going to make another
column and I will put another plot
inside that
column uh
so I'll put another plot cars in
here and so you can see you can you can
make some pretty fancy layouts with some
pretty simple constructs with just using
headings to arrange cont
content um but you know maybe maybe it's
uh you want to do something cooler um
you know so for example maybe uh instead
of instead of um putting these side by
side like that we want to make them in
tabs so we can just add a tab set to our
column heading right
there uh and now we've got them in tabs
um and so that's pretty cool um you know
but maybe we don't even want them in
tabs maybe we want them on separate
pages so why don't we put a heading one
right here and we'll make a
page and a
page page
two and now we've arranged them on
completely Standalone pages and in fact
we could have very fancy layouts on each
of these two pages uh and so you can see
the you know some some important
Concepts that work here um so one
important concept is these code cells
are very very primary so these code
cells are automatically making cards and
so that means you don't really have to
do a lot of work you know you basically
can make code cells that create
visualizations and then Place some
simple markdown around the outside to
provide the layout and
orientation um the second is you can see
you know the the headings and the
markdown that need to add to create
these layouts is really straightforward
uh and hopefully very very intuitive um
so that's gives you some of the basic
ideas now there's of course there's more
you can do um you know you can do things
like add additional navigation so I
could say like um I want a Twitter
sharing link uh and then I want a GitHub
link to the
repo and then you know we'll
automatically uh do the right thing and
figure out your GitHub URL and put a
sharing URL so you can very quickly get
some pretty nice things uh there are
more things you can do than just cards
um so for example
um you know you could do a row that's
got uh what are called value boxes uh
value boxes um you probably are familiar
with from BS lib um but if I want to
make a value box
here I can make a code cell and then I
can just say this code cell is a value
box and then this code cell really just
needs to return a list that describes
some some what what we want to show here
so let's just say uh um my
value uh value is
26 the color is going to be
red and let's even put an icon on it uh
for like
envelope
yeah and then let's make two of those
just because it'll look a little
cooler so now we've got a red and a
green value box that we've
created uh and there they are they've
showed up just as you'd expect and
what's great about this is now these
value boxes of course since they're
built programmatically can be responsive
uh you know so obviously they can be red
and green uh the icons can update to
reflect thing reflect the status uh and
so it's super straightforward now to
make these types of Arrangements um
using this quo
dashboard now uh I think the other thing
to think about and one other area that
we focused on was trying to create
experiences that were great um inside
notebooks as well uh and so here I've
got a Jupiter notebook I was showing you
a quarto markdown document now I've got
a Jupiter notebook that's building a
dashboard as well uh and part of what's
great about using the cells as sort of
Atomic units as you can see this
notebook which basically makes a pretty
nice dashboard uh is you know has a has
some markdown cells but really is just a
set of code cells with a little bit of
markdown around it to arrange it uh and
if we actually uh open up a terminal
here and actually preview
this uh
CTO review Gap
minder so if we actually preview this
Jupiter
notebook
um we will oops we will see here's the
dashboard that that creates and so uh
you know you can go and create pretty
great authoring experiences inside
notebooks even for building these really
nice and robust um bordo
dashboards uh and so um I think the last
little little bit uh for me to talk
about is uh just give you a quick look a
preview of some interactivity
um so let me just get back to so a
couple
examples uh of interactive
dashboards um and so you know obviously
the static dashboards that I showed you
help you understand the
layout but here's a nice
dashboard uh that shows some of the
interactivity and how how
straightforward it is to incorporate
things like shiny into these dashboards
so you know this is all pretty cool but
what's really cool is when you look at
the actual Source behind it and you see
how straightforward the source is we've
made a
sidebar we have the main plot we have
the data the data page uh and then we've
just mixed some code cells in there that
create the various inputs uh that that
actually render the plot and all of that
works um just beautifully and so it's
really straightforward to make both
fancy layouts and also pretty impressive
interactive
dashboards uh as I said this is coming
in CTO 1.4 um I think we anticipate that
uh early next year uh and we uh I wanted
to highlight um I think one other thing
which is uh over the past two weeks um
we've been working hard on this feature
but the rest of the company has chipped
in in a great way by helping us um both
test and generate a huge number of
sample dashboards uh we appreciate
everyone's effort and support doing that
um I have found a number of really great
bugs as a result of all that testing a
few of which are still open but I'm
getting through them uh and we also have
probably 20 great samples on the CTO
website uh most of which were
contributed by other members of the
company so uh thanks thanks to all for
your support as we sort of um grind
really hard to try to get this into qua
1.4 unexpectedly so so thanks all and
and hopefully hopefully people like what
they
see